[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, my name is Roman Nurik
from the Android Developer
Relations team.
In today's Design Bite, I want
to show you how to take an
existing icon and flatten it
to better match Android's
flatter style for things like
action bar icons or
notification icons.
Now, this is a technique that
works with Raster Icons,
things like PNGs.
Ideally, you'd be starting with
vector shapes, things
like Illustrator files or vector
shapes in Photoshop and
working on those.
But in some cases, you
simply don't have
those source materials.
And in some cases, it's actually
really hard to
replicate the icon using
vector shapes.
So let's take a look at how to
do this in Photoshop-- how to
take and existent icon and
flatten it to better match
that style.
So the first thing we're going
to do is open up an existing
graphic here.
We're going to just tweak the
setup a little bit to make it
a little easier to work with.
And we're going to create
a new fill layer.
It's going to be black.
And we're going to put
it at the bottom,
below the primary layer.
Now, the next step is to
merge these two layers.
And then go into the
Curves tool.
And this Curves tool is going
to let you tweak the
brightness values of the
pixels in your icon.
These brightness values will
in the end becomes the
transparency or alpha values
for the final icon.
So we'll take our black
background and
leave that as black.
And we'll take those grey and
we'll make that the brightest
part or the most opaque
part of the icon.
We'll then select the entire
icon, select the entire layer.
We'll copy it onto the clipboard
and we'll create a
new channel.
Now, this channel is going
to be basically the final
alpha-channel for our
resulting graphic.
And we'll paste that graphic
that have in the clipboard
into this alpha-channel.
And this is the big step, the
key step here is to then load
this alpha-channel
as a selection.
And that's going to be using
this button at the
bottom right now.
Now, once we have that
alpha-channel loaded into a
selection, we can go back into
the layers palette and create
a new layer.
And then simply fill
our selection with
a foreground color.
Now, this foreground
color should depend
entirely on your needs.
If you're creating an action bar
icon or you're using the
normal hollow dark and hollow
light styling, then you can
get the right color and opacity
values from the action
bar iconography section
in the design guide.
Or if you're trying to use a
different color that better
matches your brand, this is
the point at which you
can put that in.
So we'll simply fill the
selection and then deselect
our selection.
And then get rid of
the original icon.
And that's it.
What we're left with is
basically a layer.
You can turn this into a Smart
Object to re-size it down to
smaller sizes.
But we're left with a layer that
has a single foreground
color with no special effects
or anything like that.
And we can use this as
potentially a source material
for smaller icons.
And that's it for today's very
quick Design Bite on how to
use Photoshop to take an
existing icon and flatten it.